[تصفيق]
بريطانيا
لسنا متجر امازون لامدادات الاسلحه وسيلين
لم يعد بخفاي حنين هذه المره وموسكو تحذر
من خطوه كارثيه والحلف يتجاهل وفرنسا تمد
اوكرانيا بالمدفع الاكثر رعبا في العالم
وبوتين يصفي الجيش الروسي وكبار الضباط في
خطر وبعد عودته من قمه الناتو اردوغان
يخطب والدروس مجددا مئات الطائره وعشرات
السفن داخل الحدود التايوانيه فما الذي
يجري والمانيا تقلب الطاوله على الصين
اكبر شريك تجاري لها وبعد سنوات من التوتر
ازمه سد النهضه في طريقها للحل
تطلق صاروخها المرعب
بحضوركم شخصيا
لندن تفرغ غضبها على كيا
نكران الجميل اشد وقعا من السيف وهذا هو
حال اوروبا مع اوكرانيا فها هو وزير
الدفاع البريطاني
بان توافق مع العلاقه المتناغمه بين كيا
فولندول وطالب والاس اوكرانيا باظهار
المزيد من الامتنان لحلفائها مشيرا الى ان
بلاده ليست متجر امازون لامدادات الاسلحه
يا له من رد قاصد دورا ما الذي فعلته كياف
لتغضب لندن الى هذه الدرجه لكن الرئيس
الاوكراني فلادي مرزيلنسكي لا يهتم
للتصريحات البريطانيه وها هو يعلن انه عاد
الى بلاده بنتائج جيده من قمه النيتو في
ليتوانيا واضاف انه تم تشكيل ما وصفه
بالاساس الامني لاوكرانيا وازاله الغموض
والشكوك حول مشاركه بلاده بالناتو فعن اي
اساس امني يتحدث اما في الواقع فليس هناك
اي اساس امني اصلا حيث اكد الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ان عضويه اوكرانيا في حلف
الناتو تشكل تهديدا لامن روسيا وان احد
اسباب بدء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو
تهديد انضمام اوكرانيا الى الناتو اي ان
الحرب اندلعت كي لا تنضم كييف الى النات
ولن يسمح بوتين بذلك اطلاقا لياتي الرد
الغربي على لسان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
والذي اتهم روسيا بانها لا تؤمن بالعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وقال ان الرئيس الروسي ظن انه
بامكان جر الناتو الى حرب لكن الحلف رد
بالتركيز على جاهزيته للدفاع عن اي من
اعضائه واكد ان قوه النيتو لا يمكن
الاستهانه بها وان بوتين اخطا عندما ظن ان
الحلف سيتفكك وشدد بايدن الالتزام بالدفاع
عن امن اوكرانيا وتوفير الدعم المحدود لها
في الحرب وهنا تاكدنا من حقيقه ثابته من
حديث بايدن بان الحرب ما زالت في بدايتها
يا ساده وعلى ذكر الحرب تواصل المعارك
اشتعالها على الاراضي الاوكرانيه حيث
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
استهدفت الليله الماضيه اماكن تخزين ذخيره
للجيش الاوكراني باسلحه بعيده المدى
وعاليه الدقه تطلق من البحر مشيرا الى
مقتل 850
للقوات في جنوب اوكرانيا فجاه بعد اتهامه
لقياده وزاره الدفاع بخيانه الجنود الروس
من خلال عدم تقديم الدعم الكافي يبدو ان
بوتين يجري غربله كبيره في جيشه هذا ان
صحت هذه الاخبار واليكم مصادرها صحيفه
من خلال اعلانها نقلا عن مصادرها اعتقال
جهاز الامن الداخلي الروسي العديد من كبار
الضباط العسكريين بما في ذلك قائد قوات
الفضاء الجنرال
تقارير غربيه تتحدث عن اعتقالات صفوف قاده
الجيش في حين تم اعفاء جنرال روسي مسؤول
عن القوات التي تقاتل في جنوب اوكرانيا من
مهامه لتعود هنا فرنسا وتشعل غضب موسكو
مره اخرى وبعض الصواريخ بعده المدى ها هي
باريس تسعى لتامين الامدادات لاوكرانيا
حيث تسرع شركه نيكستار الفرنسيه من وتيره
انتاج مركبات
المزوده بمدافع قيصر ذاتيه الدفع والتي
تعتبر الاكثر رعبا في العالم فكيف سيرد
الكرملين هذه المره الرد الروسي لم يتجه
نحو فرنسا بل نحو الولايات المتحده حيث
حذر وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
من خطر حدوث صدام مسلح مباشر بين الولايات
المتحده وروسيا وذلك ان امتلكت كييف طائره
اف 16 القادره على حمل اسلحه نوويه واشار
لافراف الى ان هذا الامر محفوف بعواقب
كارثيه لان موسكو ستعتبر ذلك بمث
ابه تبين في المجال النووي وفي سياق اخر
وبعد عودته من قمه طله عقدت فيلينيوس قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه يعتزم
بحث شراء برمائيه روسيه لمكافحه حرائق
الغابات خلال لقاء شخصيا مع نظيره الروسي
يا حفيظ عثمان هل تريد اللعب على الحبلين
الاحداث والتطورات بعد سنوات من التوتر
توافق مصري اثيوبي على التفاوض اذا اتفق
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ورئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد على الشروع في
مفاوضات ثلاثيه عاجله تضم السودان ايضا
للانتهاء من الاتفاق بشان سد النهضه خلال
اربعه اشهر رصدت القوات المسلحه
التايوانيه تحلق 217 طائره تابعه للجيش
الصيني في اجوائها منذ بدايه يوليو الجاري
كما سجل التايوان ايضا دخول سفن الحربيه
الصينيه الى مياهها 71 مره منذ بدايه
الشهر الجاري وذلك وفق وكاله طاس بعد فتره
طويله من الجدل كشفت المانيا عن خطط
استراتيجيه جديده للتعامل مع نهج الصين
الذي يزداد تشددا ذلك بعد ثلاثه اشهر من
نقاشات حاميه حول مقاربه برلين تجاه اكبر
شريك تجاري لها وقال المستشار الالماني
هدفنا ليس الانفصال عن الصين لكننا نريد
خفض الاعتماد الاقتصادي في المستقبل اعلنت
كوريا الشماليه ان الرئيس كيم جونغ اون
اشرف شخصيا على الاختبار الناجح لاحدث
صاروخ باليستيا عابر للقارات يعمل بالوقود
الصلب متجاهله بهذا الاعلان الانعقاد
الطارئ المقرر لمجلس الامن الدولي لمناقشه
عمليه الاطلاق الاخيره ذكرت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان نحو 500 طيار احتياط في
الجيش ينوون تعليق انشطتهم رفضا لخطه
اصلاح القضاء المثيره للجدل في عرض تقول
انه نهائي وافقت الحكومه البريطانيه على
زياده رواتب الملايين من العاملين في
القطاع العام في محاوله لانهاء اضراباتهم
وكانت خدمه الرعايه الصحيه في بريطانيا
اعلنت انها تواجه ما يوصف ب اطول اضراب
لها على الاطلاق حيث بدا الالاف من
الاطباء في انجلترا اضرابا لمده خمسه ايام
بسبب انخفاض الاجور قال المبعوث الاممي
ورئيس البعثه الخاصه في السودان
للجزيره ان الحكومه الحاليه في السودان
فقدت السيطره على البلاد وفقدت الثقه دول
المنطقه واكد ان قرار الخرطوم بمنعه من
دخول البلد امر يؤثر على جهود البعثه في
وقت تتواصل فيه الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في مدن
العاصمه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]